oh can you tell me more of these the
minute Melody likes and tactics I wanna
I wanna see if I've seen him or if I've
ever done one okay uh what we call the
screen typically would be a simple wolf
whistle we call it a simple wolf whistle
so
um women typically will use the the the
argument in public as a manipulative
attack
so if we're in if we were here and we
had a disagreement she probably would
just storm off and use the silent
treatment she's not gonna combat me and
jump in my face but if we're in public
she's gone get into my face do something
hit me and she will raise her voice
right not not all women do this but what
I'm saying is this
yeah yeah but what they'll do is they'll
have this confrontation in public to get
people to get attention and then and
what will happen is people will watch
people are going to look and they'll
look as long as she ain't getting beat
the [ __ ] up right now now if he starts
decking her people are going to jump
into action but she used that indicator
that confrontation as a simple wolf
whistle so now she's now The Simpsons
so the simps are gonna look right alert
and then they're ready to spring into
action should the man do something now
in most cases that man has done nothing
but but um but we were gonna say he
probably did something for her to be
yelling at him
but that's not the case that's
manipulation oh that's the other thing
yeah what did he do what did he do yeah
oh
this is another one she got a lot of
them
four times a week okay I got a lot of
pent-up frustration okay okay yeah yeah
because they'll say I went crazy and I'm
okay okay okay yeah and he no no he made
me crazy and I'm like
speak for yourself right you're just
crazy correct because I'm like I I don't
I'm like I've I've been in situations
where I could have went crazy right but
I have self-control yeah yeah and
consequences yeah and yeah and and I did
not I've never hit a guy I've never you
know like but yeah these girls will be
like and I believe hit her back I know I
know the red girl the red pill guys will
be like no it's not worth it and I
understand that but equal rights equal
lefts baby we wanted equality come on if
women attacked me and I always say man
once they throw the first punch it's
it's on like Donkey Kong but I also tell
me and you know you you don't want to be
in that situation if you worked hard to
build yourself up to who you need to be
but but the um what did he do let me
give you an example let me give you an
example if uh this happens in married
couples so married couples will be
married they'll get divorced the woman
will manipulate and use the child
support system and and drag them all
right and then the guy will complained
damn she she hired attorneys she
dragging me she she just won't give me
she won't let me breathe boom yeah
what'd you do to her
yeah she can't just be a [ __ ] like
that's the worst part is like I know at
some point I wonder what he did I wonder
what he did what did he do yeah why
can't she be why can't she be the
purpose
I don't know I know that now but before
like I wouldn't have even
think of like women like that of course
which is weird because I am a woman like
I don't know why like yeah well we've
been what I tell people is we've been
conditioned significantly we don't
realize it and you only realize it when
you hear this perspective and you hear
this perspective and you're like damn
this is why y'all going in on all these
things because you don't realize that
for for 25 years of your life for 24
years of your life you've been educated
women or sugar and spice and everything
nice women don't lie if they lie they
tell White Lies they don't hurt people
and um all of these things right so men
lie they manipulate they're the cheaters
and blah blah blah but but what we know
that as is that we call that um
projection
so women are say men are dogs and they
always cheat well people cheat equally
women and men cheat equally if not women
cheat more we're learning that
they would cheat way more so I just
think more more opportunity like I think
people are equally shitty that's my but
I think but I think if you if you pay
people to make bad decisions right and
you give them more opportunity which
women have like way more opportunity
yeah and then they also do get supported
when they cheat right
um meaning that their girlfriends won't
tell you know what I mean
why
do you why why yeah what did he do yeah
and then they'll say he wasn't holding
me tight he wasn't paying attention to
me he wasn't hitting it right he lost
his job so you know what I mean that's
there's an out for her she he pushed me
into his like if the guy's like I know
you're cheating on me with Derek and
then she says well I eventually cheated
on him with Derek I wasn't at the time
but he pushed me into Derek's arms
wait a minute you weren't cheating with
Derek I accused you to cheating with
Derek and then you eventually cheated
with Derek because I said you cheated
with there this is the type of stuff
yeah I
I just the last couple of months I feel
like has changed me as a person oh you
dark hearted now yeah I just dark like
CGA
what I'm gonna tell you what it is you
want me to tell you what it is I'm the
guy that instructs people of all this
stuff many of the red pill
phrases that have come up that are I I
created I don't know if you know this
people people don't know these things
many of the phrases that are used now
some people I'm not saying all of them
but very like great I was one of the
first people but that's neither you're
there but I've come up with a lot of
phrases that people use in the changes
but it just happens well I'm gonna
educate you on something okay we call
people you know you have this red pill
blue pill Matrix and all these ideas
what typically happens is people will
discover truth it could be their truth
or it could be the truth but anyway they
discover truth now you can do one or two
things when you discover truth act like
it's not true
and continue on with your life
or you can actually accept it as true
and then live your life accordingly but
what you're going to do is be awakened
but because everything you're going to
see in your past was a lie so we call
this
accepting if your life was a lie
which is hard for people to do
we've experienced this many times and I
can't say what it is because if I
express it your channel my your video
might come down but when you were a kid
there was a guy that came down the
chimney and all of this stuff right we
eventually learned that that wasn't true
right we went well damn okay
you had a situation should I accept it
as the truth or should I go ahead and
accept this uh uh or act like it's I'll
just act like that's not true because I
want to be able to get my gifts
we actually did the Easter Bunny then
all these things not when you get an
adult you continue to face these truths
but you also have to accept that your
past was a complete lie
do you want to do that most people don't
want to do that [ __ ] and it goes on with
marriage relationships divorce romance
right we end up becoming awake and aware
and people call it bitter because they
want to play in the the untruth bubble
and live a lie their whole lives I can't
live a lie most people who live a lie
they can't go to sleep at night
most people who live at lie I live a lie
they're out of shape and fat
because they think somehow this
miraculous diet and appeal is going to
come along and get them on fat because
they've been living in a false world we
know that that's not true we live in
truth because that means I gotta correct
myself and not live a lie so people
continue to live lies and they fault
people like me and you
for not letting them live that lie
yeah it's all it is but I'm happy
they're not happy yeah and they're on
drugs you know psychomed drugs
and I'm living a great life you know so
because I've accepted hey man part of my
life was a lie
you know they said a stork brought you
to your you know the stork
we learned that your parents were you
know fornicating not fornicating
they were screwing each other
when you're an adult you find out your
careers
that part of my life was a lie
but most people can't do that with
everything
yeah it's
it's time that's that's kind of like how
my channel got like that was the first
viral video it was me like red pilling
another girl I was like
how did that go
okay
it's funny we started she started um
not thinking that trans girls should
play in our Sports
okay which is which is it isn't like red
pill necessarily but no it's really
that's the true Ripple yeah yeah and so
then but then now she like works at the
studio like she's on the show all the
time
so she got out of that yeah those things
are
um you know I study propaganda I study
manipulation we're manipulated by media
and talking points and books and in
education we're manipulating big time
again are they doing it why are they
doing it is it out of evil I don't think
it's out of evil but it's maybe out of
control
to have us on the same page there's a
whole conversation there but we were
told uh we're told our opinion because
most we call them on my show ham and
Eggers and knuckle draggers and oxygen
thieves and mouth breathers most people
don't want to think for themselves right
they just want to be told and have an
opinion now okay okay we're doing this
now that that's what it is and it's just
easier for them some people want to
challenge status quo like I'm
challenging no no no no no right no no
trans girls over here right we want to
challenge that but because how people
are educated we're the bad guys of the
challenge as many of you you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible